[Musique]
avec c'est un excellent boxeur c'est
vrai ça c'est vrai rien j'ai pas mal ici
là c'est bien ça change et je fais quoi
on savait les fonctions là ici là bien
[Rires]
sûr alors voir remettre les trophées je
voulais revenir sur une phrase poétique
tabou mais j'espère j'espère bien une
phrase romandie que vous avez sorti
cyril pour valérie benaïm dans ce moment
de poésie un temps la dorna lost la
série d'amour bien sûr est venu dans ma
loge tout à l'heure c'est vrai j'ai mis
tout nu j'ai dit je suis pas le docteur
ni connu merci à roissy soit maintenue à
aaa
je me transforme en bâtonnets ça fait
classe fois qu'on leur dit d'arrêter la
pine mais non ils se font plaisir et de
faire un pitch à une baston à la chaux
faut combattre la crise
[Applaudissements]
c'est romantique c'est pas dit que
j'aime à ce que je vous ai dit tout mais
voilà quoi tout ici ici et voulaient
absolument mettre la clim et oui et
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'en fait pour
une fois vos boules ont eu raison ses
réponses parce que oui je vous assure ce
que je connais un peu vos boules
maintenant en force à bâle christian
même base est bien le seul bateau de
larmes use alors mardi à 17h50 pour sa
vie s'il y avait c'est que de la télé la
seule émission qui est plus courte que
la météo c'est de plus en faisons
aujourd'hui ils ont un autre exilé en
russie debussy dans la musique c'est
marrant toi
alors quand soudain en plein direct la
larme à 1 109 donc on fait l'émission le
journal du hard qui est tourné juste à
côté utiliser un peu trop de fumée ça
entraîné l'enclenchement de l'alarmé
heureusement valérie bénaïm et fabien
lecoeuvre qui était invité pour son
livre ce sont des pros jusqu'au bruit
continu et valérie il peut avoir le
corona virus un plateau elle lâche pas
c'est qu'elle a beaucoup de temps alors
vous allez voir regardez ces images
impressionnantes et surtout très rare je
vous avez interviewé des dizaines et des
dizaines de centaines de personnes vous
savez que quand on pose la question on
va les riffs à bien se rendre compte en
même temps que l'alarmé incendie a
retenti ils se disent que tout va
rentrer dans l'ordre
sauf que ce n'est que le début des
problèmes on fait comme si de rien
n'était si à la maçonnerie mais tout va
bien résister si rondes vous méritez
[Applaudissements]
toi et apache et revoilà enfin bien le
que c'est un pro il fallait avoir une
tornade sur un plateau il s'en fout il
fera sa promo quoi qu'il arrive c'est
déjà du succès une première fois il
voulait me tuer la pas réussi non non
non non les stations c'est laisser des
gens qui ont comme des réactions très
extrême c'est le bruit a cassé
assourdissant mais malgré tout va bien
continuer même quand le clavier va
tomber je compte bien frapper le coeur
c'est un visionnaire parce que lui peu
importe ce qui arrive il veut parler de
son livre et valérie benaïm c'est pareil
déjà qu'elle n'a que 14 minutes
d'émission jamais albarran de l'antenne
avant la fin alors peu importe s'ils
risquent leur vie
regardez ces images qu'on exerce quand
on fait relations publiques attaché de
presse fatalement on a des plus gros
tarnais téléphone pour 2,2 du moment
tous sont pas des amis je voulais
répondre a demandé à michel je voulais
pas parce que
on l'aura compris la la constance
fortement leur chanteur préféré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
de dire ce que vous avez dit j'ai dit
que onze journées ont tourné le journal
du hard dans la pièce d'à côté donc
j'imagine et que effectivement quelqu'un
avait eu le feu au cul ah ah oui ça
c'est vrai mais cela je sais je vous dis
ça c'est que le début de la fnaim de
même par une coulée y en a eu aussi au
bénin en 2004 et c'est que vous n'êtes
quand vous êtes arrivé slalom s'arrêter
à ben jour il ya une rigolade jeudi au
téléscripteur je vous jure je suis
arrivé j'étais je garde la voiture
j'entends la larrazet je pousse la porte
ça s'arrête là je te jure que c'est vrai
c'est un truc de ouf
j'arrivais arrive à la mecque alors je
me suis dit en plus ils sont cons
belhani pas croire que c'est un coup de
fusil a répété la peur de voir ses
bosses du respect et du respect pas du
tout c'est parce qu'un hasard vous
respecte voulait que ça se passe bien
pour valérie bénaïm qui est comme ma
soeur de son a fait 15 ans qu'on est
comme ça on a échangé notre sens un jour
j'avais des grandes courses courses dans
leur voile sur tout ce qu'on vient baby
boom plutôt danseurs de seconde celle
qui m'a soufflé mais voyez la théologie
de répéter alors si banon mais c'est
resté pauvre sur de ce baume mercier
comme c'est très sympa allez-y mosson il
est temps de vous récompenser ce parce
que dans enquête exclusive à tout temps
des petites bulles mais en touche pas à
mon poste c'est tout temps des vannes
ouais alors même les invités maintenant
ils s'y mettent alors pour le award de
la meilleure vannes les nommés sont
mohamed benyamna plus connu sous le nom
de bouder diane ducret est avec nous
bien ducret que j'adore et regarder
cette boutique alors sous le dit c'est
gentil cyril hanouna pour savane
animalière allez on y va
phébus et princesses la brume
on y va tout à fait du cheval toit du
poney et ouais et richard anconina très
à l'aise quand il se fait draguer par
sophie koch saga pour vous aussi parce
que très belle émission merci beaucoup
je voulais vous remercier
c'est vrai c'est un peu acteur préféré
que je suis ravi c'est votre style
d'homme je suis là ça vous dérange pas
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire je vous avais dit que
j'avais une très bonne nouvelle
oui il se peut que la semaine prochaine
on fasse en direct joli c'est en
préparation je vous donnerai des infos
tpm peu le jeu la grande rigolade
la grosse rigolade jolie peut-être
bouder et déjà booké c'est sûr je vous
le dis peut-être qu'ils auront un
concours de blagues jeudi prochain en
direct ce serait la première fois qu'on
le fera en direct jeudi prochain
l'inutile
c'est super lançant vous merci merci on
a on a du lourd
oui on a du lourd on a déjà du goût des
on a déjà ce bien entendu on est en
train de monter un plateau qui peut être
énorme
comme on est complémentaires parce que
je parlais d'un grosse rigolade maghreb
a brassé ou les monnaies comme ça me
regarde en rouge et noir égard ne t'a
pas de cheveux j'ai pas dit si c'était
alors ça démarre fort justement avant
quelques semaines que je peux vous faire
en noir de la meilleure blague de la
grosse rigolade or on pas que ça y est
trop en manque
j'en ai sélectionné 3 3 soft 1,3 hors
d'asie mais bel est nommé pour la
meilleure blague la grosse rigolade son
leurs deux filles s'est dit satisfait
non ma femme est morte et y arrête tes
conneries
et oui je suis veuf attends attends
c'est la troisième fois que tu es veuf
il dit oui la première elle est morte
mais de quoi elle a mangé des
champignons vénéneux [ __ ] mais de quoi
elle est morte la deuxième incroyable
elle a mangé des champignons vénéneux
deux fois çi c'est incroyable l'aï la
dernière de quoi elle est morte elle
s'est fracturée le coup dit c'est quoi
un accident de bagnols fennell a pas
voulu manger les champignons jdle man
c'est une femme qui va voir son médecin
et kiki excusez moi docteur j'ai un gros
problème je je m'entends pu péter doukas
à écouter oui et donc il fait une
entorse est bon non cela prenez ces
pilules là à montréal avec s'achever
j'aime y entendre mais vous avez pété
plus fort jean marie bigard et regarde
les numéros du loto est elle à sa grille
devant lui mais ça j'ai débuté il dit
chariot là j'ai le sac j'ai ça va ils
ont gagné 27 millions alors oublions un
lot il fait des bonds de 2002 il sort il
ou au balcon il dit il dit à tout va
le coiffeur et les sharks et hyacinthe
bagot
on comprend pas bientôt ils descendent
traverse la rue et elles sont là il ya
un bus
quels travaux il sa femme le mec qui
regarde sa fin tickets dit [ __ ] la
journée ben
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pelleté le jeu spécial grosses
rigolades la semaine prochaine en direct
jeudi soir il tiendra au courant
mentalement j'étais la bonne nouvelle
puisque vous nous l'aviez réclamé on
s'est dit pourquoi pas pour moi c'est
pour quand on voit les ir amim d'arrivée
voilà et on embrasse fort il est temps
d'en venir à la seule élection qui
intéresse vraiment les français celui où
c'est le cas le plus tacler ses
collègues c'est bien sûr parler du dard
baba qui suit musique de suspense
émotion
attention cyril hamelin voilà 28 fois
d'affilée pour remporter le trophée le
plus convoité du monde
est-ce que vous ressentez une certaine
peur bon allez dès ce soir deux paires
de trophées oui j'ai peur vous avez peur
oui elle me fait me wade
geoffrey geof ou ce qui dope qui ne
savait plus trop enfouies au fond
personne qui fait foi qui vous fait pas
et jusqu'aux coudes à moi je vous dit
j'ai peur de jean michel mr amène
toujours bas eh bien écoutez justement
ce soir le 29e tard baba et contre tout
un temps
m
merci les séries merci merci croyez-moi
ça c'est vrai entre vous et jean-michel
voilà merci jean louis bravo 43 votes
d'écart c'était bien sûr qu'on va
bon bah pourquoi commence très fort vous
allez voir le tarbes a fait partie n'est
ce pas été draguée par des femmes
six ans par par là qu'elle était en
salle de sport oui d'abord une salle de
réveil
[Musique]
fanny apprendra le cyclope j'adore les
eaux je suis là touahri des dizaines de
faux noms c'est bien quoi c'est bien je
suis la marraine de thouaré j'ai fait ma
reine des trente ans il ya mon fils que
qui doivent appelé et il m'a dit oui
papa j'ai vu l'émission de benhaim ce
qu'il a regardé le saut vers chez vous
il marche très bien c'est la meilleure
c'est la séquence qui marche le mieux
dans notre vie et dégage quelque chose
tu va dégager tout court il accorde la
drague effet ses yeux comme ça
[Rires]
tu fais pas cas de jong van roekeghem à
sortir avec toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]